Harry I want to take you back to
a a startling moment in the history of
civil rights and is a moment that you
helped create I was looking at the
internet looking on the internet and
there is a clip of an interview of which
you are a part and it talks about the
leaders people who led various parts or
various contingents to the march on
Washington and in that clip there is you
Harry Belafonte there is Sidney Poitier
James Baldwin Charlton Heston Marlon
Brando mankiewicz and the interviewer
and it's an incredible ly diverse group
of people that that you were very
instrumental in putting together as a
bridge builder and and because they're
not necessarily the people you would
think would come together in the way
that you brought them together and this
was important to me personally because
there was a similar but obviously not
identical march on Washington the Julian
Bond and I participated in and this was
soma no no no I was I'm too young to be
in Selma this was the marriage equality
March in 2008 the race card but this was
the marriage equality of March in 2009
okay and what was fascinating about this
is that part of the challenge was how do
you build a bridge between the
african-american community and gay
rights which has been a wedge issue in
fact recently we hear of people actually
conspiring to create wedges between
blacks and gays and and so forth um and
one of the things that I think we were
able to achieve and make history is that
we got the chairman of the n-double
a-c-p Julian Bond and I introduced
Julian Bond at this march on Washington
to be the keynote speaker of the LGBT
rights march on Washington that was a
powerful moment but it's something that
you did you know 40 years before that
how did you achieve that collaboration
and that bridge building and what can we
learn from that today well I I think
what has to look at the that the sector
that you're talking about all those
people that you mentioned are high
profile artists they had dead more than
commanded respect and their space in
their triumph or the use of their gifts
as artists and I firmly believe it is my
belief then and now the artists are
really the gatekeepers of truth our
mission and our purpose as existing
entities is to use the gift of art to
paint a picture for our universe or for
our for the members of our universe to
be inspired to see themselves in a
higher higher realm and that artists do
that we we inscribe history we did all
the drawings on the cave walls we wrote
all the Quran and the Bible's and the
ancient sayings we were the ones that
told those letters into stone you're the
ones that created the songs and and all
the imagery and art was always been the
carrier of the history of human
evolution and we have a capacity to in
revealing the truths of life and to move
people to an inspiration inspired place
to be see life in terms of larger than
we experience has been the one entity
that all empires feel the need to
conquer so you look at the church but
almost everything that is influenced all
about the church and all the churches is
the way it was the temples have been
made ordained the way the the colored
glass windows tell you stories and the
way in which Mozart wrote all the great
symphonies and the great masses and what
you listen to when you walk into these
temples you're being overwhelmed with
the art that validates that point of
view that philosophy and when I looked
at these young men because my my charge
to me was to organize my community to
organize the cultural forces and I had
to appeal to those artists who
understood that they were the
gatekeepers of truth and at their power
if they chose to use their lights
collectively to be a huge beacon and
looking for how to change America and it
worked because when I called all these
people you just mentioned and others
their presence alone forced people to
stop and to listen and to think because
we've already invaded their inner place
they're already in their psyche
they're in their kitchens they're in
their bedrooms though listening to our
songs they made love to our songs they
march to our songs they love to come to
our movies and be influenced by how we
did what we did
they're huge force already out there and
now this collective force comes and says
let's pause for a moment and look at the
deeper truth of our society and they
carried a huge payload having their
presence there I'll never forget and
they all mingled up with people on the
mall citizens just absolutely were
aghast I'm not a ghast but but
overwhelmed with the fact that Marlon
Brando is walking with Beulah from
Mendenhall Mississippi and they're
laughing and breaking bread together
it was an untouchable moment and yet all
these things all of a sudden affected
the way people are thinking and looking
and listening and I think the use of
celebrity in that sense was what you saw
in the film and the use of that
celebrity was constantly applied whether
or Selma to Montgomery we did it anyway
you know what happened he filled of the
courtrooms of America with our presence
influencing juries and judges with our
team to say here's what we think and a
lot of times things land in our favor
but it's how you there's also an abuse
of that celebrity and a lot of guys who
are very visible very very successful
very much worthwhile in the wake of
their in north success they don't make
any pictures that help the human heart
sing or dance they don't help us see
each other and in more profound ways
they don't help us get a deeper insight
into what we should be doing as people's
matter most of what they do is quite
destructive because there's always
pictures of violence and and suspicion
and it's always so it's evil overcoming
justice and the guy who was always them
the hero he's always smitten with a lot
of evil in this character but it's also
the way it was the system is co-opted
culture and his use culture to service
it because the the dilemma that the
nation faces in this cult in this in
this economic collapse and the social
collapse it's very evident in the arts
because we are also in a cultural
collapse near the lowest ebb of America
cultural power the way our songs are the
way our voices are the books that are
written the things the way which we've
engaged culture is really at an all-time
low and I think if that changes a lot
will be changed and the social rhythm
our social vision it's an amazing thing
to have at our disposal